die korona krise ist zurück auch in
deutschland die infektionszahlen
schnellen nach oben 4000 neuinfektionen
allein von mittwoch auf donnerstag die
bundeskanzlerin geht sogar davon aus
dass wir zu weihnachten 19.200 fälle pro
tag neu haben könnten
dazu sind die bundeshauptstadt und die
finanz metropole berlin und frankfurt
risikogebiete dazu bremen plus
landkreise und kommunen und in
deutschland kann man nicht einmal mehr
frei verreisen
fragen wir den mann der in deutschland
zuständig ist für das krisen-management
hallo herzlich willkommen herr spahn
danke winter katheter ersparen
angesichts dieser zahlen wie knapp
stehen wir vor dem corona
kontrollverlust
das haben wir selbst in der hand und
zwar wir alle gemeinsam alle bürgerinnen
und bürger nämlich im alltag
es geht darum durch aha regeln ist es
banal aber sehr wirksam abstand wie gene
alltags maske vor allem im geschlossenen
raum ein unterschied zu machen und vor
allem wissen wir ja auch aus den letzten
monaten wo gibt es eher geringere
risiken beim einkaufen friseur im
nahverkehr im flugzeug mit den regeln
die die da sind haben wir das gut im
griff und wird jetzt größere risiken das
ist insbesondere beim feiern wenn wir im
geschlossenen raum auf engem raum
miteinander sind bei religiösen
zusammenkünften zum beispiel
dort haben wir ausbruchsgeschehen und
wenn sie die frage stellen kontrolle
oder nicht kontrolle dann kann ich das
nur sagen das haben wir alle gemeinsam
selbst in der hand je nachdem wie wir
den alltag gestalten hand aufs herz
können sie einen zweiten locker und
ausschließen was wir sicherlich einfach
besser können als im märz april mit dem
wissen von heute so richtig die
entscheidung damals mit dem damaligen
wissen waren
so können wir doch heute eben besser
differenzieren ich habe gerade schon
gesagt es gibt bereiche einzelhandel
etwa bei friseuren im nahverkehr
da sehen wir mit den maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben ist das gut im griff
da gibt es keine ausbrüche solange die
aha regeln eingehalten werden und die
hygiene konzepte es kann aber wieder zu
beschränkungen kommen das tut es hier
auch in berlin in münchen in anderen
großstädten in anderen regionen mit
hohen infektionszahlen beim feiern bei
veranstaltungen bei auch zusammentreffen
im öffentlichen raum
dort gibt es dann eben die notwendigkeit
auch wieder lokal
in der beschränkung zu haben das ist
aber etwas anders als im märz
die bundeskanzlerin hat trotzdem jetzt
für diesen freitag zum krisengipfel
getrommelt und zwar mit 11 regierenden
von deutschen großstädten was läuft in
deutschlands großstädten falsch was wird
dort falsch gemacht was läuft aus dem
ruder
wir werden morgen ich werde dabei sein
morgen mit den oberbürgermeistern
bürgermeistern dieser städte zum einen
darüber reden wo wir auch unterstützen
können als bund etwa in den
gesundheitsämtern mit der bundeswehr zum
beispiel in der kontaktpersonen nach
verfolge wir werden darüber reden was
eben auch das besondere ist in den
metropolen wir sehen ja auch ganz
deutschland übrigens auch auf ganz
europa bezogen
es sind vor allem die ballungsräume in
denen wir ein größeres
ausbruchsgeschehen haben vor allem
sondern diffus ist wissen sie über
tennis gütersloh wussten wir einen
betrieb und da kam es her wir sehen in
anderen bereichen eine pflegeeinrichtung
da ist der ausbruchs kern sozusagen und
wir sehen in den großen städten dass das
an ganz vielen stellen ist und sich vor
allem im zweifel eben aus feiern aus dem
was auf den plätzen nachts stattfindet
zum beispiel sich dann entsprechend
ergebnis wir wollen mit den
bürgermeistern darüber reden wie man das
am besten adressiert die ballungsräume
und dann die feiernden jugendlichen
droht uns eine spaltung in alt und jung
und in stadt und land erlebt gerade ganz
unterschiedliches erlebt familien die
ihren herbsturlaub banken auf denen sie
sich sehr gefreut haben ich erlebe
andersrum auch familien die sich sorgen
machen um die ältesten und die höchste
takten die großeltern in der familie
gelebt jugendliche die sich nach
freiheit sehen und unternehmer die um
ihre existenz bangen
das ist gerade eine zeit die uns alle
sehr auf die probe stellt und eine zeit
die verantwortung sind ausdauer
solidarität miteinander braucht und das
ist ja das was wir erleben in diesem
alltag das sind sind herten und
einschränkungen die diese pandemie mit
sich bringt und gleichzeitig haben wir
den letzten monaten gelernt wenn wir
aufeinander aufpassen wenn wir einander
achtgeben aufeinander acht geben etwa
bei den a ha regeln
dann können wir dieses virus auch unter
kontrolle behalten und das gibt doch
auch zuversicht also mir ist wichtig
beides zu sehen wir können zuversicht
haben mit den erfahrungen der letzten
monate und wir brauchen achtsamkeit mit
den entwicklungen der letzten tage den
eigenen infektionszahlen aber die
tonlage heute hat sich doch deutlich
verändert sie klang heute anders der
chef des robert koch institutes klang
anders
auch die bundeskanzlerin klang heute
beim deutschen handwerks tag deutlich
anders ich möchte nicht ein zweiter
locker und hat sie gesagt ich möchte
nicht dass ich das aus dem frühling
irgendwie wiederholt die tonlage ist
eine andere ist noch dramatischer als es
jetzt bei ihm klingt die tonlage seiner
die einfach den bürgerinnen und bürgern
sagt wir haben es selbst in der hand wir
haben es in der hand ob wir das
erreichte verspielen
die gefahr ist da die zahlen wissen sie
ich werde manchmal gefragt wenn es in
dieser kipp punkt ab wann entgleitet es
ab wann können wir das nicht mehr
kontrollieren den kann ich ihnen nicht
auf eine zahl genau benennen ich kann
ihnen im nachhinein sagen aber
ehrlicherweise möchte ich den gar nicht
mit ihnen oder uns allen hier in
deutschland austesten ich möchte gar
nicht dass wir so weit kommen und darum
geht es die bürgerinnen und bürgern uns
allen gemeinsam gilt ja um unser aller
alltag einfach deutlich zu machen wir
sind an einer wegmarke in dieser
pandemie eine andere jahreszeit
herbst/winter wir werden wieder mehr im
geschlossenen raum seien generell
atemwegserkrankungen sind im herbst und
winter häufiger und deswegen geht es
jetzt darum einfach deutlich zu machen
es ist ernst
es geht um achtsamkeit aber mir schon
auch wichtig es geht ihm auch um
zuversicht nimmt wissen was wir erreicht
haben ich halte nichts davon wenn jeden
tag irgendwie alarm und panik ist dann
ist wenn jeden tag alarm ist es gar kein
alarm mehr sondern ich finde es einfach
wichtig dass wir das gut einordnen stand
heute können wir damit umgehen
schwierig wird es wenn die dynamik sich
fortsetzt dann können wir nicht mehr
damit umgehen und das ist die botschaft
dieses tages wir haben wieder
verschärfte regelungen was aber bringen
immer neue regelungen und neue
verschärfungen wenn am ende nicht
kontrolliert wird wir sehen es sie
selber auch in berlin und auch anderswo
wird nicht kontrolliert von den kommunen
und dann wird ganz viel abgewählt auf
gastronom und auf die hoteliers was
bringt all diese verschärfung wenn am
ende nichts kontrolliert wird wir spüren
das sehen wir übrigens auch in umfragen
es gibt eine hohe akzeptanz für die
maßnahmen die gibt es aber vor allem
dann wenn es eine gewisse
einheitlichkeit gibt und auch eine
konsequenz gibt bei regeln oder eben
beim nicht einhalten von regeln und
deswegen denke ich schon auch wir
brauchen ich ständig neue regeln wir
müssen regeln die da sind dann auch mal
kontrollieren und ich glaube schon
wissen sie das erlebe ich ja auch in
berlin es gibt sehr viele gastronomen
sehr viele veranstalter die halten
sich daran die führenden gästelisten die
sorgen für abstand und bitten die gäste
oder fordern sie auch klar auf die maske
zu tragen
aber es gibt eben zu viele wohl nicht
darauf geachtet wird und wenn es dann
manchmal auch empfindliche bußgelder
gibt dann wird sich das schnell
herumsprechen und dann sich auch wieder
mehr dran halten das ist wie mit zu
schnell fahren wenn es nie kontrolliert
würde würde so ganz langsam schleichen
sich wahrscheinlich irgendwann keiner
mehr dran halten
dadurch dass wir immer wieder alle
gemeinsam auch mit einer
stichprobenartigen kontrolle rechnen
müssen und wer auch alle wissen dass es
eigentlich besser ist nicht zu schnell
zu fahren für die anderen vor allem die
man schützt dadurch funktioniert das
sind alles in allem ganz gut also wir
brauchen auch kontrollen zumindest mal
stichprobenartig auch durchaus mit
empfindlichen bußgeldern dann sehr sehr
schnell bin ich sicher werden sich auch
die allermeisten wieder dran halten dies
im moment nicht tun gleichzeitig dass
ich mir aber schon auch wichtig haben
wir viele und die schützen war damit
auch dies tun sie haben selbst noch vor
vier wochen den deutschen herbst und
winter urlaub in deutschland empfohlen
zur eigenen sicherheit
wo sollen wir denn jetzt noch urlaub
machen bei den reisebeschränkungen die
wir jetzt haben
da sehen sie übrigens wie schnell das
war vor fünf sechs wochen hat sich das
gesagt habe anfang september wie schnell
sich die lage verändern kann wir hatten
vor fünf sechs wochen in deutschland
noch ein anderes infektionsgeschehen
niedrigere infektionszahlen das hat sich
jetzt verändert und damit gibt es eben
auch risiken innerhalb deutschland
stärker beim reisen bei der mobilität
ich finde aber wichtig dass wir eine
einheitlichkeit zwischen den
bundesländern haben ich spür sehr stark
auch in der rückmeldung aus dem eigenen
umfeld aber eben auch in dem was uns im
ministerium erreicht von den bürgerinnen
und bürgern viele sind schon bereit auch
zu akzeptieren dass sich was ändert
selbst wenn schwer fällt auch er wird
sich beim urlaub was ändert aber sie
möchten einfach auch nachvollziehen
können warum jetzt was gilt welcher test
jetzt gilt wann der test gemacht sein
muss und da gibt es im moment zu viele
unterschiedliche regeln zwischen den
bundesländern nicht versteht die länder
gut die sagen wir haben niedrige
infektionszahlen mecklenburg-vorpommern
schleswig-holstein andere bundesländer
die sagen natürlich wir wollen nicht
dass das virus sozusagen zu uns kommt
per mobilität verstehe ich gut aber wir
brauchen eben auch ein einheitliches
vorgehen um akzeptanz zu behalten
sehen sie noch durch bei diesen
flickenteppich den wir haben wäre wohl
in quarantäne muss wie jetzt gerade wo
noch über
achten darf es ist im moment tatsächlich
so dass man immer also auch ich für jede
reise in eine region erst mal schauen
muss jetzt genau gilt und das wissen sie
unsere stärke bis hierhin war doch
eigentlich dass wir es geschafft haben
immer wieder
es hat zwischendurch mal geruckelt so
ist das im föderalen miteinander 16
bundesländer ein bunt unterschiedliche
lagen dass wir immer am ende eine
gemeinsame linie gefunden haben
gemeinsames ziel gemeinsame linie
gemeinsamen rahmen und ich kann nur
dafür werben und uns ermuntern das jetzt
eben auch vor allem jetzt in dieser
beginn der herbstferien zeit zügig auch
für die innerdeutschen reisen
hinzubekommen
apropos innerdeutsche reisen anfang
dezember ist der cdu-bundesparteitag im
landkreis esslingen an der stadtgrenze
zu stuttgart 1000 delegierte sondern aus
ganz deutschland auch aus risikogebieten
anreisen
gleichzeitig sind die zahlen für private
feiert wie hochzeitsfeiern für
trauerfeiern und für hochzeiten arg
limitiert und hoch begrenzt kann man in
so einer zeit ein solches groß event
noch guten gewissens durchführen vor
allem wenn der veranstaltungsort in
einem risikogebiet liegt wenn sie sicher
die verantwortlichen die organisatoren
in der cdu und die verantwortlichen in
den gesundheitsbehörden den
gesundheitsämtern vor ort die werden das
rechtzeitig entscheiden
dank gespannt für das interview gerne
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren